I think Liz truss is not showing huge
amount of accountability she is
basically saying the system failed her
she talks about the treasury Orthodoxy
the left-wing economic establishment as
she puts it I think people will be
saying hold on Liz truss and
quasi-quarting were warned about what
was going to happen and ultimately it
was her own MPS in 1922 committee that
decided that it was time for her to go
she does say that mistakes were made
when it came to Communications she got
things wrong on that she does say that
she takes some accountability but I
think there will be people certainly on
Twitter who think that she needs to show
more Contrition after being widely
blamed for badly damaging the economy
seeing the man that she beat over the
summer in the hustings pulled into uh to
clean up the mess that she made we
haven't been seeing a huge amount from
Liz truss she's been so spotted around
the estate
met with a flurry of excitement over the
last few months but this really for her
is a kind of big political comeback
moment her setting out her side of
events trying to reignite her political
career from the Wilderness
um she as we know has done an ace of 4
000 word essay we expect there'll be a
TV interview and she's done this
interview with the telegraph I'm going
to read you another quote where she
explains some of what she thinks went
wrong she says I underestimated the
resistance inside the conservative
parliamentary party to move to a lower
tax less regulated economy the fewer
over the reduction to the top rate of
income tax was Testament to this in the
overall package of measures it was in
fiscal terms little more than a rounding
error equivalent to 0.2 percent of
government spending even though the
measure was economically sound I
underestimated the political backlash I
would face which focused almost entirely
on on the Optics so Liz truss trying to
set out her version of events I think
the question now is what does all this
mean for Rishi sudak should he be
worried I think
um there's there's no kind of sense that
Liz truss is heading back into number 10
anytime soon but I think the message
that she brings with her does try him
with some on the back benches there are
growing calls um from the conversations
I've had for more tax cuts and they do
um some MPS as one put it to me Liz
truss is not the returning Messiah but I
do want to see growth they do want to
see more of a plan for growth from the
chancellor and of course the timing is
key with a budget just around the corner
next month and the first bit of
electoral test really for Rishi sunac in
May of the local elections okay Ali
let's talk about migration immigration
refugees what more do we know about
potential plans to block a migrant's
right to appeal if they are sentenced to
deportation
we know that this is something the
government are extremely Keen to focus
on to having have an impact in time for
the next election they know it's
something that's cutting through on the
doorstep and they also know that what's
been tried so far hasn't worked
um we know they know that there's a
joint action plans negotiations with the
French sending money there
um hasn't brought down the numbers the
borders bill which was all about
penalties for people Smugglers penalties
for people crossing your channel doesn't
seem um to have had much of an impact so
what they're looking at now is
effectively excluding people that cross
a channel in small boats from being able
to be part of the Asylum system in this
country and stopping appeals from
happening either at all when they come
to this country or not until they go
back either to their home country or
third country for example Rwanda where
we know there's been a partnership this
was something that Sophie Ridge asked
the business secretary about this
morning and here's what he had to say
the direction here is quite
straightforward if you come here via an
illegal route so you come here to claim
Asylum and you know in the first place
the way you're getting here is not legal
you haven't got an airplane you haven't
got a commercial service you've just
been trafficked illegally then if you
come here by that route then you you
shouldn't get uh rights
well this has been met with anger from
some Charities Refugee Council calling
it wrong unworkable and costly but the
government as I say making this a top
priority as I expect will get more on
this legislation over the coming weeks